There you are.
Who doesn’t love dogs?
Golden Retrievers.
Chocolate Lab.
A German Shepard.
A Yorkie.
Pugs.
Jack Russell.
What else?
And a Boxer.
Oh, we’ve got a lot of dogs.
Puppy Place is about two kids,
Lizzie and Charles,
who fall into the joys of fostering dogs.
A puppy!
They try to find dogs homes
and have to deal with different situations
that come with fostering dogs.
This truly is a dream come true.
Hahaha.
No, I'm serious.
I actually dreamed about it.
I’ve been a dog person my whole life.
Dogs, everything else.
Each book for us is really a jumping off point.
Sixty-five books with more coming.
So I was like, “This is fantastic."
I promise.
It’s specifically about the children
and how they are learning life lessons,
learning responsibility,
and the way they do that is through their friendships
and through fostering
and re-homing dogs.
Trust me.
We can handle it.
Lizzie’s very smart
and determined
and she knows everything
and anything about dogs.
You know more about dogs
than most adults I’ve worked with.
Charles is
a problem solver.
He always tries to help the dogs.
I'm putting him in the crate.
It'll help him get comfortable
in his new environment.
Tucking him in like we used to do with you,
except Jack’s not asking for a little more screen time.
Real funny, Dad.
They put everyone else’s needs
before their own.
This is Princess, our new foster puppy.
Your son
is my hero.
We have a different dog every episode.
So with these dogs,
Lizzie and Charles try to find
people who mostly match the dogs
and dogs that mostly
match the people.
I don’t think we’re a match.
Seems too
elegant, and I'm a man of the people.
What do you think I love about playing Lizzie?
The dogs!
I grew up with dogs.
Dogs are awesome.
Just full of love.
Dogs comfort us.
We came to cheer you up.
They're loyal.
They kind of do everything we need for us
without asking much in return.
I'm ready for my lunch.
One of the most rewarding parts of doing the show is that
the cast and crew
get to adopt the dogs.
And it’s really cool because
sometimes when they adopt dogs
we get to see them again.
Totally.
Local residents in nearby businesses…
I really hope Dad's okay.
Well, he could certainly use a hot shower.
Dad!
I think one of the biggest lessons is
family comes first and
we all need each other.
Mm-mm-mm.
Doing this felt good
and I think when people watch it
they’ll be able to feel good watching it.
It's also really cool
to be a part of a show that has
such a great message about
rescuing dogs.
We did it!
Yes!
We want people to think about
animal rescue,
animal fostering.
And if you like dogs, then it's a good
show for you to watch.
It's fun, and it's organic,
and it has honestly been the most fulfilling experience
of my life.
That's
Puppy Place in a nutshell.